[Music]
morgan is in atlanta georgia hi morgan
welcome to the show
hi thank you
um
my husband and i both work in a volatile
industry we were introduced to your
principles about 18 months ago and
immediately went into store mode
since then we've saved 50 000 and i
started a second career
unfortunately we found ourselves feeling
dave ish wavering in and out of
emergency mode
as we found success with my second
career using that to pay off some debt
refinance our house cash flow
emergencies and do some home
improvements we still have
000 in debt though and i'm wondering you
know can we continue on this path using
my second career um to to finish paying
off the debt
uh and preserve our 50k we've paid or is
it time to just decide
you know you're either in store mode or
you're not and
how do you do home repairs when you're
in a snow storm home renovations when
you're in a storm mode
it's
illogical my second
income my second but you're in storm
mode
you're too scared to pay it on the debt
but you're not too scared to fix your
kitchen up
i'm i think i'm more scared to not have
money i haven't i still have two careers
you fixed up your kitchen
no i didn't i i didn't
what was the home renovation
well it was a home improvement it was a
retaining wall
okay so why couldn't that wait if you're
in storm mode
that's why i'm calling yeah my point is
is that you're picking and choosing when
you decide you want to be afraid or not
i don't want to be afraid when i'm
talking about my income from the new
career i don't want to be afraid when
i'm talking about doing something i want
to do which is a retaining wall
but when i want to pay off debt now i
want to be afraid
i guess i'm i'm afraid i'm going to use
that savings and then i'm going to lose
you used it for a retaining wall
that's my second job and it's
it's all your income
it's all your income it's all one pile
there's no bifurcation here
okay
you're not getting it you are really
inconsistent in this
and so you got to decide what you is
you got to decide are you going to keep
running this plan or are you going to
say
all right
this storm mode thing is not real or it
is real if it is real it means you don't
need to do any
thing with any
money
except pile it up
that's that's storm mode okay we think
we're gonna lose our jobs our careers
are volatile and we're gonna be on the
street homeless and we just need to stop
and know no retaining walls
no vacations
no eating out
we're afraid we're going to lose our
income
so we're not willing to work a plan
until we can get stabilized we are
pushing pause on any progress of any
kind anywhere in our life and piling up
cash getting ready for a nuclear winter
that's storm mode
if you're not that scared
then you need to cash all this thinking
money out and quit screwing around and
get out of that
okay and i think that's i think that's
the one you need
is get out of it and how do we know when
we're in a volatile industry how do you
know when
how do you feel good about exiting storm
mode
well there's okay there's two kinds of
fear here
how long have you been doing this
volatile industry
my entire career
for how many years
um
15
and how many times have you been without
income
zero
okay so
the volaloe industry thing is a
mythology
i hope so no honey it's 15 years and
you've made money every year
it you know you you're just afraid of
the fact it goes up and down
but the actual facts are disputing your
feelings
okay
aren't they what am i missing
um
i i don't know i just am not confident
in my career i mean this is the least
confident i've ever been what do you do
i'm an airline pilot
okay all right
well today they could use your help
they can but they also could determine
that
because i've chosen medical freedom yeah
i understand that you've got to be put
on the street
you could be put on the street okay
so until the storm passes you don't need
to do anything else or until you get
your income up
in another area which means the storm
has passed you don't need to do anything
else
and so um
i don't disagree with your conclusions
or your stance or anything else it's not
the point uh but
for 15 years the airline
pilots have not been volatile i mean
it's the er the income is irregular
based on how much you work or don't work
but the chances of you being completely
out of work for the last 15 years it's
higher at this moment than it has ever
been based on your choices
but i mean airline pilot so what okay
the the other thing is is that you are
an airline pilot now what that means is
that you prepare
for your job every day against only and
or mostly against worst case scenarios
right everything you do is to avoid a
crash
it is in your it's in your nature thank
god because that's what you're good at
right i mean i don't really want you
flying unless you do that okay so i'm
not it's not a criticism but the very
the very essence of your job is to
constantly prepare for worst case
scenarios
it's safety thank you exactly exactly
but that that translates then in your it
gets into your nervous system and that
translates over to your checkbook
and you go okay i'm gonna run my
finances the way i fly the airplane i'm
gonna only prepare for worst case
scenarios and i'm gonna pretend like
we're about to crash at any moment and
i've really got to have thought through
every checklist i've got to thought
every backup switch i got to throw
every scenario right and because that's
what you guys do i mean you're really
good at it thank god that's why we have
very few airline crashes so um
you know you guys your your profession
is amazing but but the the essence of
your profession doesn't help your
nervous system
adjust to your finances your finances
are a lot safer
than
you you shouldn't run your finances like
you fly an airplane that's what i'm
trying to say
okay that makes sense
it does so you guys have a lot of money
you've done very well you're gonna be
okay
how much notice do you think you'll get
you're not gonna get put on the street
in 24 hours
you're probably going to get you're
probably going to get six months or
90 days anyway notice on uh
on vaccine right
uh yeah it'll take two to three months
yeah okay
if that actually happens let's worry
about it then
okay
in the mean in the meantime because let
me just say this way okay let's pretend
that that you had no money
because you put it all on the debt when
you get off the phone here
this is a great conversation by the way
thank you for calling hello terrifying
i love it i love it well i mean i'm
messing with you because but it's it's
really a good conversation so let's
pretend you got you had put all the
money today on the debt
and you had no cash except a thousand
dollars because you're working the baby
steps pure
okay
how much debt have you got
about 65k
oh my god you're almost debt free when
we write this check then okay
uh but let's pretend you're not that
that you got 15 000 in debt
because we wrote 50 towards it today
and you got the call tomorrow right
after you wrote those checks and the
money was already out the door
that you got 60 days
if you didn't do anything
at all for 60 days except pile up cash
you'd have a really big pile of cash in
60 days wouldn't you
we we could come up with some yeah yeah
i'm talking about you do nothing no
retaining walls no going out to eat no
nothing and you use all three sources of
income and you just do nothing
and you pile up cash because it's an
emergency
you'll be okay you guys you're in good
shape i'd write a check today and i'd be
moving towards debt freedom i think
you're going to be debt-free and i think
that's going to change your whole
vision on your second career and on how
you react to those first careers demands